TREY: WELCOME BACK TO SUNDAY
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN
AMERICA," OUR NEXT GUEST WAS
ELECTED TO HAWAII HOUSE.
AND SHE WAS A LEADER IN
CONGRESS ON MANY ISSUES.
AS A DEMOCRAT.
SHE WAS VICE CHAIR OF THE
DNC IN 2016, AND SUPPORTER
OF BERNIE SANDERS AND RAN
FOR PRESIDENT HERSELF AS A
DEMOCRAT.
IN 2020 SHE WAS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE COLLEAGUES, MANY
MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES WILL
TELL YOU THE SAME, WE DIDN'T
VOTE ALIKE BUT SHE
HONEST AND FAIR.
JOINING US NOW TULSI
GABBARD.
ALOHA, WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU,
LET'S START WITH THE WHY AND
WHY NOW.
WHY DID YOU LEAVE THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY AND WHY NOW?
>> TREY, 20 YEARS AGO, WHEN
I JOINED THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, I RAN FOR STATE HOUSE
IN HAWAII, I WAS DRAWN TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE
OF LEADERS LIKE MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND JFK, A BIG
TENT PARTY INCLUSIVE THAT
STOOD FOR CIVIL LIBERTIES,
INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM, LIMITED
GOVERNMENT AND A GOVERNMENT
THAT WAS TRULY OF, BY AND
FOR THE PEOPLE.
UNFORTUNATELY OVERTIME, WE
HAVE COME TO A POINT WHERE
NOW TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS NONE OF THOSE THINGS.
IT IS NOW A PARTY THAT IS
OF, BY AND FOR THE ELITE AND
A PARTY THAT IS IN THE
CONTROL OF FANATICAL
IDEOLOGUES WHO OPPOSE
FREEDOM, THEY ARE ACTIVELY
TRYING TO UNDERMINE OUR
FREED OF THE SPEECH, TELLING
US WHAT WE HAVE TO THINK,
READ, AND SAY, AND HEAR,
THEY ARE AGAINST FREEDOM OF
RELIGION.
THE LIST GOES ON, BUT IT
COMES DOWN TO FACT THAT
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THE PARTY IN CONTROL IN
WASHINGTON IS DANGEROUSLY
OPPOSED TO OUR GOD-GIVEN
RIGHTS ENSHRINED
IN OUR CONSTITUTION, IT IS A
PARTY I CAN NO LONGER LIVE
WITH.
TREY: YOU HAVE --
YOU DON'T DO ANYTHING
WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT IT.
I GUESS, WHAT PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN ASKING ME, WAS HOW LONG
HAD YOU BEEN THINKING ABOUT
IT?
SOMETHING SPECIFIC?
OR RECENT?
A WHY NOW, PART.
>> SURE, YOU KNOW, I HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN INDEPENDENT
MINDED, OVERTIME I WOULD SAY
OVER LAST FEW YEARS, THERE
HAVE BEEN ONE EXAMPLE AFTER
ANOTHER OF POLICIES AND
ACTIONS UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION ESPECIALLY
THAT ARE UNDERMINING OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND
FREEDOMS, DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THAT IS PUSHING US, THEY
HAVE BECOME A PARTY OF WAR
MONGERS, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY USED TO BE HOME TO
CHAMPIONS OF PEACE, WHO
RECOGNIZE FOR US TO BE FREE
AND PROSPEROUS WE MUST
ACHIEVE PEACE.
THOSE VOICES ARE SILENT IN
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT WASN'T THAT IT WAS IN ONE
SPECIFIC MOMENT, BUT IT WAS
OVERTIME SEEING COMPLETELY
HOW THE THINGS THAT TODAY'S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS STANDING
FOR, THINGS THAT ARE GOING
AGAINST THE VERY VALUES AND
FOUNDATIONS OF OUR COUNTRY.
TREY: TULSI, U.S. IS
PRIMARILY A TWO-PARTY
COUNTRY, IF YOU ARE NOT A
DEMOCRAT, HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE YOURSELF, IS THERE
A PARTY OR
LABEL THAT FITS YOU, THERE
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
>> I AM NOT THINKING ABOUT
PARTY AFFILIATION.
BUT I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AN
INDEPENDENT-MINDED PERSON.
IF YOU ARE ASKING ME, I'M AN
INDEPENDENT.
TREY: YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN.
SINCE I MET YOU, YOU HAVE
BEEN INDEPENDENT.
I WAS MAYBE AMONG LEAST
SURPRISED PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE A NEW PODCAST,
TULSI GABBARD SHOW, I HAVE
NO IDEA HOW YOU CAME UP WITH
THE NAME.
>> CREATIVELY.
TREY: DO YOU SEE -- NO LESS
CREATIVE THAN MY OWN SHOW
TITLE.
DO YOU SEE YOURSELF EVER GET
BACK ELECTIVE OFFICE,
OR ARE YOU CONTENT.
YOU HAVE A HUGE PLATFORM,
REPUBLICANS LIKE YOU MORE
THAN ME, I TELL THEM, THE
FACT THAT SHE IS NOT A
DEMOCRAT DOES NOT MEAN SHE
IS ONE OF YOU.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS FOR YOURSELF?
>> YOU ARE ASKING IF I'M
CONTENT, I'M NOT.
LIFE IS SHORT.
AND THERE ARE MANY, MANY
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE HERE
IN THE COUNTRY, MANY IN THE
WORLD.
THE TULSI GABBARD SHOW IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO HAVE
AN UNFILTERED AND UNLIMITED
PLATFORM TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT MY VIEWS AND
PERSPECTIVES ON A LOT OF THE
ISSUES AND TALK WITH OTHERS
WHO ARE EXPERTS WITH
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES AS
WELL TO BETTER INFORM AND
ENGAGE AND GET TO US A PLACE
WHERE WE TOGETHER AS
AMERICANS CAN MOVE FORWARD
TO STARTING TO SOLVE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS, LIFE IS SHORT
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE
EVERYTHING THAT I CAN TO
SERVE GOD, AND TO SERVE
OTHERS AND TO MAKE A
POSITIVE IMPACT.
WHETHER THAT LEADS BACK TO
ELECTED OFFICE IN FUTURE OR
NOT, TO ME KIND OF
IRRELEVANT.
THE QUESTION I ASKED MYSELF
S HOW CAN I MAKE THE
POSITIVE IMPACT.
TREY: AMEN.
YOU DID IN MY LIFE AND LIVES
OF MANY OF YOUR COLLEAGUES,
ONE OF YOUR FAVORITE
COLLEAGUE.
YOU KEEP BEING TULSI
GABBARD.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TREY: AND YOU WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL NO MATTER WHAT.
I CAN'T WAIT TO TALK